oh my gosh I have to say too God you
walked in today and I just saw what you
were wearing you walked in I was like
and then you walked out today like in
this and I was like oh my gosh you have
you always been into fashion yes is it
just natural for you well no speaking of
the church you know the black church is
a fashion show yeah and I'm first
generation post Civil Rights Movement so
you know I was taught that the first
impression uh is what you look like so
you must dress up I came from the you
dress up in suits I wore a suit to
school I wore jacket and a tie to public
high school you know dress for the job
you want not the one you have was what
my great a Dorothy told me so you know
there were lots of combinations of that
and then I've been able to now
use uh my fashion sense as activism yeah
I like that make political statement as
well yeah and you I feel like every time
I see you like on a red carpet like
literally you are a
walking fashion but also SL political
statement there's always something
happening that that's deeper and I love
that always dual yeah yeah and that's on
purpose it's always on purpose
everything I do is intentional okay I
love it everything I do is on purpose
yeah you know and because I've lived
long enough I've been in this business
for 35 years I made the decision that
what I wanted to do as an artist was to
use my art to heal oh yeah of course my
art art is healing because it's so
healing for us it's heal and I want to
share that
m
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home